luis you you came here today to you know
to
to tell your side of the story yes
uh it's been a while since you and i saw
each other
when is the last time that you two have
seen each other
the last time i've been in her house
like three years ago maybe
in several years that was exactly when
and for the pros and the divorce
well molly and louise had a tumultuous
relationship when they were together
which
made it hard for her to trust someone
new let's take a look at some of their
biggest clashes
as a couple the man that i fell in love
with
was not who i thought he was you want my
kid to go live with her dad
this is not what i expected at all
it's like you just don't care you have
the period now
everything you speak is like crazy right
now
i never see one bible here so what about
somebody who drinks every day
or who doesn't want to take care of
children and love on them
you are to my kids you are
demanding and commanding of me
how dare you i don't understand what
you're saying
yes you do turn the speaker off
turn off the speaker nobody wants to
hear all that luis you're not calling
the cops dude stop it
turn off the music this is my speaker
and nobody wants to hear this
it's ridiculous you need to go after
almost an entire year of being married
louise was gone
molly what was it like for you to relive
those moments
honestly it's sad and pathetic because
i felt like i was losing my mind like it
was crazy
so yeah it was
really a volatile breakup where did you
go
after you left molly's house okay after
she
fired me out of her house kicked my ass
out of the house
i went to new jersey to my brother's
house
i'm just laughing like he just said
after i
fired him out of my house i
i just think that's really funny wow
obviously
when the day came that our divorce
papers were final you
said i need copies of the paper so that
i can get married
so clearly
there was good reason for the firing